do i have to call your lady stop now  yes  you shouldn't have run from the guards i  didn't run  you need better guards  what suits you lady stark  john left you in charge he did  i hope he comes back soon i remember how  happy he was to see me when he sees you  his heart will probably stop  it doesn't look like him should have  been carved by someone who knew his face  everyone who knew his face is dead  we're not  they say you killed joffrey did you  i wish i had  me too i was angry when i heard someone  else had done it  however long my list got he was always  first  your list of people i'm going to kill  how did you get back to winterfell it's  a long story  i imagine yours is two yes  not a very pleasant one my neither  but our stories aren't over yet  no they're not  you